[Musique]
l'argonaute s'est de nouveau complexe
sportif et culturel du quartier de
l'argonne à orléans il a ouvert ses
portes en septembre 2010 est on y
pratiquait une quarantaine de
disciplines
[Musique]
lassé de violonistes serge ceccaldi
également directeur de l'association
musique et équilibrer ses 400 élèves qui
dispose désormais d'une antenne dans un
dieu tout beau tout neuf
[Musique]
ici on pratique la musique actuelle le
chant la guitare la batterie et
l'acoustique a fait l'objet d'une
intense réflexion
on a fait une réflexion sur à la fois la
typologie des espaces et à la fois sur
le traitement du son à l'intérêt de ces
de ces salles pour accueillir des
musiques actuelles
en fait on fait en fait un aménagement
particulier pour les salles de musiques
actuelles qui sont généralement très
très sonore donc en fait faut faire des
panneaux informant qu'ils peuvent
permettre de travailler dans de bonnes
conditions sans être complètement
envahie de toutes les semaines et des
notes qui peuvent rebondir dans les
différents panneaux de cette salle
il est très bon d'une manière générale
on a plutôt un son de qualité on a
plutôt ces instruments aussi qu'ils vont
bien donc
le son est le son est bon avec son
acoustique performante l'école est en
passe de devenir une nouvelle scène
musicale locale
malgré sa situation excentrée dans un
quartier d'orléans dits sensibles suivre
oui oui c'est un quartier sensible mais
mais j'ai vécu dans plusieurs quartiers
sensibles dans d'autres villes et je
veux dire ils sont sensibles à certains
moments et puis il ya d'autres moments
ils sont moins sensibles et puis voilà
on aime bien être aussi c'est pratique
on se gare facilement
il faut changer les habitudes et c'est
ça la vie aussi c'est aller sur des
territoires nouveaux et prendre un peu
la vibration et encontre du monde le par
et pour l'association musique et
équilibre c'était aussi de s'implanter
dans une structure où la culture côtoie
le monde sportif
de mettre un lieu de culture au sein
d'un gros bâtiment sportif avec des tas
de matières enfin de d'activités
différentes c'est un plus pour le pour
le lien pour le tissu social et tout
l'articulation peut y avoir entre le
vivre ensemble et les personnes qui
viennent occuper cet espace